I want to bring up the inspiration like
your inspiration with the with the
fashion you've used I want to bring up
those pictures once again this I
remember this first one I think were you
at the Oscars right there yes the Oscars
the Oscars was really where it's where
it popped off there was a Golden Globe
before that which was my first time on a
major red carpet but when the Oscars
called I knew you know this is the
entertainment Super Bowl my friend Adena
Manzel a few years prior um you know her
name was said wrong and I saw TW we all
saw Adele deine and then she became a
household name because of that and the
businessman inside of me was like well
what when ABC called to ask me to be on
the red carpet I said well what is my
what is my wrong name calling going to
be like what is it yeah what will be
memorable also have a message like I
when I saw that dress I was like well
hell I'd wear that like I love I love
that and my thought was you know because
I used to always say when I was in at
Carnegie melan and drama school we would
have Oscar parties and I would be like
I'm I'm not gonna wear that penguin suit
I'mma wear I'mma wear a gown I'mma wear
a gown and it's interesting because
words do have power yeah even when
you're not conscious of it so 30 years
later 25 years later whatever I'm asked
to do this thing and I was like oh I
remember I said I was going to wear a
gown to the Oscars and so I got to
Christian Serano and I thought well if
it starts if it's if the shot starts
here and it looks like just a
traditional tuxedo and then when you
pull out it's a full gag I know it'll
change the world because there's more
than just the top you know what I'm
saying there's more to to a person than
even one outfit I love it I'm not am not
that into fashion that's why I love
watching it because I don't innately go
I am like the person you hate I wear
like workout clothes every day and I
don't work out on
them it's like look they're
comfortable practical I am 100%
and you have two children I know and and
is cool now I would love to blame it on
the children I was this on tour before
yeah I've always been this person but I
love watching it you know I'm not a
painter but I love art like I love I
love all of
[Music]
[Applause]
that thank you guys y'all have a great
night guys I'm going
home